foreign
[Music]
how could you possibly know that
we've got one hope
all America's industrial might and
scientific innovation connected here
secret Laboratory
keep everyone there until it's done
let's go recruit some scientists
build a town build it fast we don't let
scientists bring their families will
never get the best
why would we go to the middle of nowhere
for who knows how long
why why
because this is the most important thing
that ever happened in the history of the
world
you're the great improviser but this
you can't do in your head
are we saying there's a chance that when
we push that button we destroy the world
chances are near zero
near zero what do you want for Theory
alone zero would be nice
[Music]
is a matter of life and death
but I can perform this miracle
World War II would be over our boys
would come home
that's happening isn't it
world
will remember this day
I work here
will ensure a peace mankind has never
seen
[Music]
until somebody builds a bigger one
you are the man who gave them the power
to destroy themselves
and the world is not prepared
hey
seven
six five
four
three Truman needs to know what's next
what's next
who do you think the best driver is
probably Rory I would dust him in a lap
yeah all you do is play video games with
some crazy dreams of racing cars you're
the one that told us to always do
something we love
cars cost
look around it's not our world son
what is this it's a contest
the best Gran Turismo players in the
world
get a chance to compete in professional
racing dude this is real
[Applause]
is really
I'm sorry you really think you're gonna
take a kid who plays video games in
their bedroom you're gonna strap them to
a 200 mile an hour rocket it'll tear
them to pieces
it's not gonna work the guys who race
are Elite athletes
your kids are scrawny little gamer kids
that's why you coming come on let's go
must be a new experience for you moving
your legs
you puked on my lawn there's no turning
back now when you're in a race the
cockpit is going to be 140 degrees
Fahrenheit
g-forces will be twice what an astronaut
experiences upon liftoff I can't see
anything
hey you get extra points for that in the
game Jesus Christ
this whole thing is insane but out of
the Couchsurfing nerds that you sent me
he is the best one he made it
welcome to Team Nissan
[Music]
of the game is called racing
out there if you miss the line in the
game you reset you miss it on the track
you could die
I know this track
man I've raced it a thousand times
that's what I'm talking about
[Music]
This
Bitter Earth let's say an open road
helps you think about where you're going
where you been
from the first night we met my heart
[Music]
for quarter mile at a time
the things change
[Music]
you drive just like your dad
I'm afraid of losing someone I love
[Music]
so impressive
what good am I but this is your last
ride
[Applause]
you made one mistake never thought my
Man's family the great Dawn Toretto how
you choose the ones you save
where am I one of us might not come back
from this what good am I everything that
we've done
that is worth a thing if I lose you
if this is a Finish Line
[Music]
ride or die remember
promise
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
it's an ancient ecosystem Untouched by
man whatever is down there is trying to
make its way to the surface
this is a bad idea just a little bit
[Music]
foreign
biggest bag anyone's ever seen
everybody back into the station
three massive exit who knows what else
can escape the breach
I just hope it goes better than last
time
what happened last time
I wanna know
[Applause]
you've never seen this before they
hunted it back
we can relax this place is magproof
Venturas was always afraid of this but I
was also thinking
[Music]
is
barracuda
it's breathtaking
[Music]
when you see sand here imagine water if
you dive in you can't reach the bottle
you Dives in yes it's cold swimming I
don't I don't believe you
in the shadows of arrakis lie many
Secrets but the darkest of them all may
remain
thank you the end of House of treaties
no father didn't believe in Revenge
what if Paula treaties were still alive
have you ever had a dream about your
first ride
don't try to impress anyone
you're brave we all know that
be simple
be direct
nothing fancy I understand
nothing fancy
[Music]
you will never lose people tradies
we gave them something to hope for
May thy knife chip and shatter
[Applause]
[Music]
we all write our own stories there is
Richard I'd like to speak to him I'm
here
this is mine
that's me the middle Meadow Mr Richard
Montagne I'm the guy who helped bring
the world the most popular snack it's
ever seen are you ready
I've been ready all right all right it
was a little bit more like this
spicy yeah see that's how I got here
dear God please forgive me for the gang
the drugs it's going cars what the heck
man let's move it hey he's open now
bye baby
the guy started at the berry bottom I
know I don't look it but I got a PhD I'm
poor hungry and determined sir okay I
can see you're gonna be a weird one
what's happening well son lots of them
Frito-Lay isn't getting enough orders to
keep the Factory open who's Cool Ranch
anyway
[Applause]
that lady
what is it
stop eating itself
I had been searching for an answer
and there it was
they had been there the entire time
you got an idea it's a spicy Camp it's
gonna change everything and we'll save
our Factory and you're a janitor we're
gonna go hang on
figure out the next step see the
Hispanic market will not be ignored the
Hispanic market will not be ignored it's
good but in your voice
we're wasting time on this janitor is
crazy ideas guys like you want me we'll
get shots like this you see that guy
right there I see a chingonies
get out there and be great
we wanna know that we matter to you if
we know that there was a product out
there for us we'd say hey
I got a little Hood there at the end but
[Applause]
[Music]
it's good
I am honored to introduce to you the
creator of The Hunger Games themselves
Dean casca High bottom
I have summoned you all here for the
10th Annual reaping ceremony in which we
choose two children from each district
to fight to the death in The Hunger
Games from District 12 Lucy gray bear
[Music]
there has been a change this year as a
mentor Mr snow Your Role is to turn
these children into spectacles not
survivors
what does my mentor do besides bring me
roses I do my best to take care of you
you really want to take care of me in
that Arena
you start by thinking I can actually win
I'm lucky flickerman first ever host of
The Hunger Games
[Music]
enjoy the show
what happens in there
filled with the terror becoming becoming
free
see how quickly we become predator
see how quickly civilization disappears
foreign
[Music]
to us all
across that line into evil
or not
you hear that boy
it's the sound of snow
falling
how wonderful that we all get to be here
for someone's final performance
everything is about winning
it's the things we love most
that drives us
I can't believe it I just can't believe
it
no can I
feel like I just saw him
yeah he just called me last week
it was a butt dial
still
what are we gonna do where was durfy the
happiest easy Harrison is perfect you
know what you think about it that is
where it all began
oh my God it's spring break
[Music]
you remind me of my granddad Granddad
how old do you think I am I don't know
how old 40.
[Applause]
store games
oh my God I get her number welcome to
the ultimate game this is our reminder
to be mindful be mindful of history and
history and Bay Street just kill us now
[Music]
your chariots went
this is gonna be fun isn't it buddy
these people suck
what will your journey be because once
those are magic mushrooms I just ate 10
of these things come on you got a trip
I'm not taking any mushrooms I'll eat
these pink things though guys
[Music]
your hair up
One Tap of the tongue is the most
powerful hallucinogenic what are you
doing you're welcome sweetheart
[Music]
[Applause]
nine seconds
that's what I'll give you to decide your
fate
[Music]
what did you do back home
government work I'm retired
[Music]
because of these people I'm beginning to
understand real people and I'm starting
to believe
this is where I'm supposed to be
thank you
what happens to you happens to many
times the mafia they like cancer
no cue
you should say all of other people's
business
whatever it is you and your friends do
do it somewhere else you warning me I'm
preparing is that a Timex no it's a
boost that's the median nerve but I'm
compressing
that's a level three you don't want it
to go to a level four
oh
[Music]
seem like a man who understands violence
can't take that from me
anything I want
police found multiple dead bodies on
that farm in Sicily do you kill him
[Music]
nine seconds
do I look like a killer
[Music]
my name is Sharon and I'm an alcoholic
for this wooden headache
my advice
find a reason to be here that's bigger
than you are I read about this family in
the paper I think this is it
we have a situation
well maybe just a little off the cheeks
God is here with us right now and we are
here with you something about that
little girl without a mom sick when the
family bled dry from all the hospital
bills I think I'm supposed to help hi
Sharon yes man I just wanted to come by
and give you this I just made dinner if
you want to stay would love to
what are you doing I met this woman
mess perfect she'll fit right in 400
000 Plus in medical bills all three
credit cards maxed out your income's
only 3 600 a month yes ma'am that's not
good ad no ma'am I'm gonna put together
a press kit for a corporate donations
that kind of thing
smile
girls help your daddy out
I've owned four small businesses I'm
good at plenty of things taking No for
an answering one of them Daddy's in the
first head they're asking us to reduce
the family's medical bills due to
hardship no I'm asking you to erase them
all of them
was that funny
[Applause]
[Music]
oh you want to go on an adventure
Michelle will need to fly 700 miles to
the Children's Hospital you're telling
me we need a plane now how exactly do
you recommend we get a plane doc okay to
you playing I promise
we are going to save this girl you hear
me we're gonna need a lot of shovels
[Music]
how did it become your responsibility to
save her because I'm here
because I can
[Music]
for centuries Our Kind has stayed hidden
on Earth
the darkness has found us again
Prime
about the fate of all living things
Unicron is coming
[Music]
back up Oh I thought we were boys
what a human here I'm nobody I ain't
even seen nothing I'm not even seeing
anything right now
foreign
[Music]
Optimus we must trust each other to
protect the home we all share
how big can this guy be uh he eats
planets so like way bigger than a planet
in the end
everything you cared for
will be consumed
maybe there's another way to save our
home
you've never faced anything like this
let them come
[Music]
yo Noah Take the Wheel
foreign
[Music]
10 years ago we created the robots who
now do the tasks Americans once did
Thomas Newton was sentenced to 28 years
after he had an illegal robot double of
himself you hear that robot yes
this Hugo is different level I'm glad
you've met a nice young lady I need you
completely focused on getting a
horizontal for me put yourself a deep
program and I'll see you too
Charles guy really wants to bang me so
he'll have to take over tomorrow too yes
Elaine just don't want the night to end
I feel the same way too Byron E2 pick up
your phone I've never done this before
one two three
Elena also has a robot double you are
dating a robot all along you two and I
are running away together don't try to
stop us goodbye Elaine goodbye let's
just talk about this don't do it
childish
this is terrible they've completely
stolen our lives I'm gonna have to get a
real job we hunt them down and we kill
them um two cappuccinos thank you you
guys don't understand they're not going
to be obedient anymore
they're humanizing they're learning to
feel you want to get married immediately
let's go away to stop our weddings
enjoy ride is over
hey I get to shoot me sorry I couldn't
resist well fine that I'm shooting you
that's not fair
oh my God oh my God I shouldn't turn
again
just deprogram now she's ferals
all right ladies picture time
we have to help them
thanks for helping me yes
[Music]
I
just need me
haven't given me a choice
I'll kill you
[__] kid
just the two of you running all this
land
that's right and who's this
yeah I'm sorry I talked to him
it said that mother is the name for God
on the lips and hearts of all children
she can be glorious
fulfilled with wrath
and if anyone was ever hurt her family
there's no telling what she'd be capable
of
[Music]
foreign